This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个爱心播客。保证是真人。2%。这是指那些在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇异的现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是数字2。访问IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难学习法》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。这并不意味着你拥有这种能力。并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在Iheart广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。你好，欢迎回到你的二十岁心理学，这是一个讨论我们在二十岁时遇到的一些重大生活变化和转变以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back for another episode. New listeners, old listeners, it is so great to have you here. Today, we're going to be breaking down yet another topic that impacts us in our 20s and diving into some of the psychology and the science behind what happens. So let's get into it. Today, we're going to talk about seasonal depression. Seasonal depression. It is, I think, such a popular topic. It's become a much more common phrase, which is brilliant anything to, I think, destigmatize or expand our understanding of different disorders and illnesses that afflict us is so important. I'm sure for many of our listeners, they are probably going into the winter months. If you're in the US, if you're in the UK. And for my elderly listeners, perhaps we're finding ourselves. exiting this period of maybe even depression or sadness, low motivation as the summer season begins. And we're having some of those classic sunny Aussie days. Maybe you are a bit of a winter baby, someone who loves the cold, loves the chill, the shorter days, maybe even the snow. That is definitely not the case for myself. I love the sun. I'm such a summer baby.
大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎收听又一期节目。新听众，老听众，很高兴有你们在这里。今天，我们将剖析另一个影响我们二十岁生活的课题，并深入探讨我们身后发生的事情背后的心理学和科学。让我们开始吧。今天，我们要聊聊季节性抑郁症。季节性抑郁症。我认为这是一个非常受欢迎的话题。它已经成为了一个更常见的词组，这太棒了，任何能够去污名化或扩大我们对折磨我们的不同障碍和疾病的理解的事情都是非常重要的。我确信对于我们的许多听众来说，他们可能正在进入冬季。如果你在美国，如果你在英国。对于我年纪较大的听众，也许我们发现自己。随着夏季的开始，正在摆脱这种甚至可能是抑郁、悲伤、缺乏动力的时期。我们正在享受那些经典而阳光灿烂的澳大利亚日子。也许你是个彻头彻尾的冬季宝宝，一个喜欢寒冷、喜欢冰凉、喜欢较短的日子、甚至喜欢雪的人。这绝对不是我的情况。我喜欢阳光。我绝对是个夏季宝宝。
and I have definitely struggled with periodic seasonal depression and found that not only can it be really misunderstood, but sometimes not understood at all. Regardless, really, of where you are in the world, whether you are suffering through a few sullen winter days or enjoying the sunshine, Seasonal depression, I think, is an essential concept and experience for us to understand in our 20s and really at all stages in our life. It's essential knowledge, really. The weather and our environment, it impacts our mood in such an interesting, complicated, nuanced way. So we're going to discuss that impact and we're going to talk about seasonal depression, what it is, why it occurs, what it feels like. and how we can protect ourselves as best as possible from some of the feelings that come along with the dark, sometimes sad, winter months.
我绝对一直在与周期性的季节性抑郁症作斗争，并发现它不仅会被真正地误解，有时甚至根本不被理解。无论你身处世界何处，无论你是在几个阴沉的冬日里饱受折磨，还是在享受阳光，我认为季节性抑郁症对于我们在二十岁时以及实际上在我们生活的各个阶段来说，都是一个至关重要的概念和体验。这确实是必不可少的知识。天气和我们的环境，它们以一种如此有趣、复杂、微妙的方式影响着我们的情绪。所以我们将讨论这种影响，我们将讨论季节性抑郁症是什么、它为什么会发生、感觉如何。以及我们如何才能尽最大可能保护自己免受黑暗、有时悲伤的冬日所带来的某些情绪的影响。
So buckle in. Let's jump into some of the psychology, some of the science, the lessons of seasonal depression. So seasonal depression, you've probably heard about it at some stage, maybe in discussions with your friends. are in the media, TikTok, from your workplace, you know, posters warning you about seasonal depression in the winter months. It's, I think, a really amazing thing that this disorder, which is, you know, really it is a disorder, is becoming more understood and becoming acknowledged as something that really does impact quite a few people. And it's not really like a walk in the park. It's not some lesser version of depression, it is very much an emotional state marked by sadness,
所以系好安全带。让我们深入探讨季节性抑郁症的一些心理学、科学和教训。所以季节性抑郁症，你可能在某个阶段听说过它，也许是在与朋友的讨论中。或者在媒体上、TikTok上，从你的工作场所，你知道，有海报警告你在冬季要注意季节性抑郁症。我认为这是一件非常了不起的事情，这种疾病，你知道的，它确实是一种疾病，正变得越来越被人理解，并被承认是一种确实影响了相当多人的东西。这真的不像在公园散步那样轻松。它不是某种低配版的抑郁症，它在很大程度上是一种以悲伤为标志的情绪状态，
marked by low motivation, that comes according to the months. But sometimes the science behind it is not well communicated. And I think it can be really beneficial for us to understand from a psychoeducation perspective why it is that the seasons, that the weather, that our environment has such a profound influence on our mental health and our mental state at any given time. So seasonal depression is actually a bit of a layman's name or a casual name. And sometimes that can confuse us into thinking it's somewhat of a made-up concept, some kind of like fancy spin on normal depression or what we perceive as normal depression.
以动力不足为标志，随月份而出现。但有时其背后的科学并没有得到很好的传达。我认为，从心理教育的角度来理解为什么季节、天气、我们的环境在任何特定时间对我们的心理健康和心理状态产生如此深远的影响，对我们来说真的很有益。所以季节性抑郁症实际上是一个通俗的名字或随意的名字。有时这会让我们感到困惑，认为它有点像一个捏造的概念，某种对普通抑郁症的奇特包装，或者我们认为的普通抑郁症。
But it is a really serious thing. And the professional name for this experience is seasonal, effective disorder. So by the seasons, effective meaning emotions, and then disorder, meaning that it can be classified in the DSM. Someone pointed this out to me the other day that the acronym for seasonal effective disorder is actually sad, which I think is quite ironic. I don't know who was in charge of naming it, but I think they're spot on. So essentially seasonal effective disorder, it's a type of depression that's related to changes in the seasons. normally it begins and ends around the same time every year for a person. If you're like most people, like myself, who experiences this disorder, your symptoms, they normally
但这是一件非常严肃的事情。这种经历的专业名称是季节性情感障碍。所以由季节决定，情感意味着情绪，然后是障碍，意味着它可以在DSM中分类。前几天有人向我指出，季节性情感障碍的首字母缩写实际上是sad（悲伤），我认为这相当具有讽刺意味。我不知道是谁负责给它命名的，但我觉得他们一针见血。所以基本上季节性情感障碍，它是一种与季节变化有关的抑郁症。通常它每年在同一个时间左右开始和结束。如果你像大多数人一样，像我一样经历过这种疾病，你的症状通常会
start in autumn and they continue into the winter months. So they start as the sun starts setting earlier and rising later and it can make you feel really moody, you can feel your energy levels quite quickly plummet. These symptoms, luckily for us, often. resolved during the spring and summer months. And it's also incredibly common, really, really common impacting up to like one in ten people. But there was a study done by the National Institute of Mental Health quite recently actually. And yeah, it said one in ten people will have some form of seasonal effective disorder in their life. It's also more common in women than it is in men. And in
从秋天开始，并持续到冬季。所以当太阳开始落山得更早、升起得更晚时，它们就开始了，这会让你感到非常喜怒无常，你会感觉到你的能量水平相当快地下降。幸运的是，对于我们来说，这些症状通常在春季和夏季消退。而且它也极其普遍，真的非常普遍，影响高达十分之一的人。但国家心理健康研究所最近确实做了一项研究。是的，它说十分之一的人一生中都会患某种形式的季节性情感障碍。它在女性中也比在男性中更常见。在
some areas or countries or regions where not only is there a very significant change in seasons, but those winter months are a lot harsher. Interestingly, when I was researching this, I also found this out. There are actually some people who have almost reverse seasonal effective disorder. So instead of the winter seasons and the winter months, the colder months, being the ones in which they experience these symptoms of depression, it's actually the summer months, the warmer months, that cause these periods of intense sadness.
一些地区、国家或地区，不仅季节变化非常显著，而且那些冬月要严酷得多。有趣的是，当我研究这个时，我也发现了这一点。实际上有一些人几乎有相反的季节性情感障碍。因此，不是冬季和冬月、更寒冷的月份成为他们体验这些抑郁症状的时间，实际上是夏季、更温暖的月份导致了这些强烈的悲伤时期。
But that is a lot less common, and we're going to explain why. When we get into the science, you'll see why that's the case in a second. I think one of the big common misconceptions about seasonal depression is that it's just like the winter blues, when the days kind of get darker and colder, and we have less sunlight, less daylight, less kind of bright hours to go out and be social, to explore.
但这没那么常见，我们将解释原因。当我们进入科学领域时，你就会在一秒钟内看到为什么会这样。我认为关于季节性抑郁症的一个很大的常见误解是，它就像冬季忧郁症一样，当时白昼变得更黑、更冷，我们的阳光更少、日光更少、出去社交和探索的光明时间更少。
It's not unusual to experience temporary feelings of tiredness or stress or even anxiety. But seasonal affected disorder is much more serious. It is a form of clinical depression. And the symptoms can last sometimes even beyond those periods of winter or autumn or the colder months. and kind of extend beyond when we would typically see them, which can obviously cause some pretty big problems. The other thing to note and the other kind of close, the way to kind of point out, the close relationship between full-blown clinical depression and seasonal depression is that it shares almost the exact same symptoms with clinical depression, with the exception that
经历暂时的疲劳、压力甚至焦虑的感觉并不罕见。但季节性情感障碍要严重得多。它是临床抑郁症的一种形式。而且症状有时甚至会持续到冬季、秋季或寒冷月份的那些时期之后。并有点超出我们通常看到它们的时候，这显然会导致一些相当大的问题。需要注意的另一件事情以及另一种密切相关的、指出成熟的临床抑郁症与季节性抑郁症之间密切关系的方式是，它与临床抑郁症几乎完全共享相同的症状，除了
it normally comes and goes with the seasons and with a specific season, in particular. If you're someone who right now thinks they might be experiencing seasonal effective disorder or seasonal depression, as it's known more colloquially, these are some of the kind of symptoms or, I don't like to say side effects, but the experiences you might be having. So you might be feeling really listless, really sad or down, and really unable to pull yourself out of that funk. for it to be kind of deemed as seasonal effective disorder, this has to last for longer than a couple of weeks. You know, everyone has a couple hard days, especially when it's cold. It's not always an equation for the happiest of moods,
它通常随着季节和一个特定的季节而出现和消失，尤其是这样。如果你现在觉得自己可能正在经历季节性情感障碍或季节性抑郁症（正如它更通俗的称呼），这些是你可能会有的一些症状，或者，我不太喜欢说是副作用，但可能是你正在经历的事情。所以你可能会感到非常无精打采、非常悲伤或沮丧，并且真的无法让自己摆脱那种沮丧的情绪。要被视为季节性情感障碍，这必须持续几周以上。你知道的，每个人都有几天艰难的日子，尤其是当天气寒冷的时候。这并不总是能带来最快乐的心情，
but for it to be classified as a disorder, it does have to last a little bit longer than just a few days or, you know, just an afternoon. The other thing we might notice is that we lose interest in the activities that we once enjoyed. We just cannot find the motivation to do them. You have low energy, you feel sluggish, you might be experiencing insomnia or on the flip side,
但要被归类为一种疾病，它确实需要持续比几天或仅仅一个下午更长的时间。我们可能会注意到的另一件事是，我们对曾经喜欢的活动失去了兴趣。我们就是找不到动力去做它们。你能量低，你感到迟钝，你可能正在经历失眠，或者反过来，
sleeping way too much, have cravings, particularly for high energy foods like sugar and carbs, have difficulty concentrating. That was a big one for me. And then some of those other symptoms that we, can sometimes see as a bit more severe, feeling really hopeless or worthless or guilty, questioning your worth and your value or your kind of meaning in life. And then again, kind of falling into a bit
睡得太多，有食欲，特别喜欢高能量食物，如糖和碳水化合物，难以集中注意力。这对我来说是个大问题。然后是我们有时会认为更严重的其他一些症状，感到真正绝望、毫无价值或内疚，质疑你的价值和你的价值或你在生活中的某种意义。然后再次，每年冬天降临在我们身上时，几乎陷入
of a pit of despair almost when those winter months kind of fall on us each year, feeling like this is some inescapable kind of hell for the next little while. and really struggling to get your mind around that and feel like you can function in this kind of season. Obviously, this can vary from person to person, and these symptoms can also linger for quite sometimes. Sometimes, like we said, past the actual season, up to five months, but normally in order to get a diagnosis of seasonal effective disorder, if you go to a professional or a clinician, it does need to be kind of contained in a particular season or in a particular kind of a weather environment, I guess is the best way to put it. So I'm sure we can all see how difficult this may be for our well-being, right?
绝望的深渊，感觉在接下来的这段时间里这是一场不可逃避的地狱。并且真的很难围绕这一点调整心态，觉得自己在这个季节能够正常运转。显然，这因人而异，这些症状也可能会持续相当长的一段时间。有时，正如我们所说，会超过实际的季节，长达五个月，但通常为了获得季节性情感障碍的诊断，如果你去看专业人士或临床医生，它确实需要被包含在特定的季节或特定的天气环境中，我想这是最好的表达方式。所以确信我们都能看到这对我们的幸福有多么困难，对吧？
If we spend three months or more of the year, depending on where you live, in a state of essentially depression and in a state of mental and physical hibernation, where we're unable to manage our everyday lives, it's incredibly difficult to feel optimistic about wanting to do things, wanting to be social, wanting to go out. Like I said before, this is certainly something I've struggled with, and I would even say pretty severely. Obviously, I don't think it's any secret from, what I've shared on this show about my experience with antidepressants and anxiety,
如果我们一年中有三个月或更长的时间（取决于你住在哪里）基本上处于抑郁状态，处于精神和身体的冬眠状态，无法管理我们的日常生活，那么要对想要做事情、想要社交、想要外出保持乐观是极其困难的。就像我之前说的，这绝对是我一直在挣扎的事情，我甚至可以说相当严重。很明显，从我在这个节目中分享的关于我使用抗抑郁药和焦虑症的经历来看，这并不是什么秘密，
that this is something that has impacted me at various periods across my life, especially when I used to live in Canberra, which is the capital city of Australia. It gets so cold there. I think for many of you who might be listening overseas, there is this kind of international impression that Australia is this constantly sunny oasis, which is definitely the case if you're living in some of the northern, parts of the country, but in Canberra, it's like, kind of like smack bang in like the middle of all, like, the mountains and the cold areas of Australia, and we would get these terrible,
这是在我一生中的不同时期对我有影响的事情，特别是当我过去住在堪培拉的时候，那是澳大利亚的首都。那里冷极了。我想对于许多可能在海外收听的你们来说，有一种国际印象，即澳大利亚是一个持续阳光明媚的绿洲，如果你住在该国北部的一些地区，这绝对是事实，但在堪培拉，它有点像，就像是在澳大利亚所有山脉和寒冷地区的中间的猛烈撞击，我们会经历可怕的，
like, bone-chilling winters. The sun would set at like 4.30pm and rise at like 9. Maybe for those of you who are listening, you have much longer winters, that doesn't sound very extreme, but for me, it was so intense. And while I lived in Canberra, I used to like track the days to the winter solstice, which is the shortest day of the year. And I would track down the days. I remember it was like June 30th or something like that. And every year I would wait for that day, knowing that when it reached that point,
像，刺骨的冬天。太阳会在下午4:30左右落下，在9点左右升起。也许对于你们这些正在收听的人来说，你们有更漫长的冬天，这听起来不是很极端，但对我来说，它是如此强烈。当我住在堪培拉时，我过去常常追踪到冬至的日子，冬至是一年中白天最短的日子。我会追踪那些日子。我记得大约是6月30日左右。每年我都在等待那一天的到来，我知道一旦到了那个节点，
things would hopefully and slowly kind of start getting better for me. I just remember this one winter where it was really, really hard. There were other things going on in my life at the time. And I would just sit in bed all day and almost feel panicked and anxious when the sun would say, and it would get dark, feeling like I'd wasted another day, feeling like, oh, I wasn't able to get into the sun. I wasn't able to, like, go outdoors. And if you can relate to this, then it might be something to consider. It's worth considering whether you're kind of laps and your fall and your drop in mood around the cold winter months might actually be seasonal effective disorder. It's not
事情有望并且慢慢地开始对我好转。我只记得有一个冬天真的非常非常艰难。当时我的生活中还有其他事情在发生。我整天坐在床上，当太阳落山变黑时，几乎会感到恐慌和焦虑，觉得自己又浪费了一天，觉得，哦，我没能沐浴阳光。我没能，像，去户外。如果你能对此感同身受，那么这可能是需要考虑的事情。值得考虑的是，你在寒冷的冬月里情绪的消沉、下降和跌落是否实际上是季节性情感障碍。这不
just the winter blues. It might actually be some form of clinical depression. especially if these feelings and symptoms peak during the colder winter months. I think personally, I think this is really exacerbated by the concept of the 9 to 5 work week. You know, we spend every waking hour of sunlight during winter, either in an office or at uni or in some kind of like indoor building. like the 9 to 5 period is often blocked out by some activity. Normally that's work. That leaves literally no time before the sunrises.
仅仅是冬季忧郁症。它实际上可能是某种形式的临床抑郁症。特别是如果这些感觉和症状在寒冷的冬月里达到顶峰。我个人认为，这被9到5的工作周的概念大大加剧了。你知道的，我们在冬天的每一个清醒的日光小时里，要么在办公室，要么在大学，要么在某种室内建筑里。像9到5这段时间通常被某些活动所阻断。通常那是工作。这字面上留下了日出之前的时间。
And after we clock off, maybe it's like at half an hour of sunlight during our lunch break if we can brave the cold weather to like eat outside. That's all we get. We spend our entire days without exposure to natural light on our face and on our skin and on our bodies. This is obviously not how. any living creature is meant to be. Like, you're not meant to be indoors without natural sunlight. Like, that's not how our bodies and our brains and our systems were made. That's not how they evolved. So when we can't access these kind of essentials for life, like the sun, like fresh air, like the outdoors,
在我们下班之后，也许就像午休时间有半小时的阳光，如果我们能勇敢地面对寒冷的天气在外面吃饭的话。这就是我们得到的全部。我们度过了整整一天，脸上、皮肤上和身体上都没有接触到自然光。这显然不是任何活着的生物应该有的方式。就像，你不应该呆在没有自然阳光的室内。这绝不是我们的身体、大脑和系统被创造的方式。这不是它们进化的方式。所以当我们无法获得这些生活的必需品时，比如阳光、新鲜空气、户外，
especially when that's exacerbated by the winter months, when the sun starts setting a lot earlier and rising a lot later. and we're kind of working our nine to five jobs or pushing through uni or pushing through exams, it can be so detrimental. So this is a great segue into our next discussion on why it is that seasonal depression occurs and the science and psychology behind it. Our next partner has a product I use literally every day. I started taking AG1 because I've been on a bit of a health journey. I wanted to take better care of my immune system.
特别是当被冬季加剧时，当太阳开始落得很早，升得很晚时。我们正在做着朝九晚五的工作，或者在大学里硬挺，或者在考试中硬挺，这可能是如此有害。所以这是我们对下一场讨论的绝佳过渡，讨论季节性抑郁症为什么会发生以及它背后的科学和心理学。我们的下一个合作伙伴有一款我字面意义上每天都在使用的产品。我开始服用AG1是因为我一直在进行健康之旅。我想要更好地照顾我的免疫系统。
system and my gut health. And with one delicious scoop of AG1, you're essentially absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins, minerals, probiotics, all that good stuff. And it's really great for your nervous system and your immune system. It's just one simple micro-habit that you can incorporate into your daily life with big benefits. It's super lifestyle friendly. And Athletic Greens is also a climate neutral certified company, which we absolutely love on the show. Right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with a convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop in a cup of water every day. That's it.
系统和我的肠道健康。只需一勺美味的AG1，你基本上就能吸收75种高质量的维生素、矿物质、益生菌，所有这些好东西。它对你的神经系统和免疫系统真的很好。这只是一个你可以融入日常生活的简单微习惯，却有着巨大的好处。它非常符合生活方式。Athletic Greens也是一家气候中和认证的公司，我们在节目中绝对喜欢这一点。现在，是时候通过便捷的日常营养来重塑您的健康并武装您的免疫系统了。每天一杯水里只需一勺。就是这样。
No need for a million different pills and supplements to look after your health. And to make it easy, Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one-year supply of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash Gemma. Again, that's athletic greens.com slash. Gemma, to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance. So there are quite a few psychological and biological explanations behind why we might experience seasonal affective disorder or seasonal depression. And a lot of these answers rest in
不需要数百万种不同的药丸和补充剂来照顾你的健康。为了方便起见，Athletic Greens将在您首次购买时免费为您提供一整年的支持免疫的维生素D和五个免费旅行装。您只需要访问athletic greens.com斜杠Gemma。再次强调，那是athletic greens.com斜杠Gemma，以掌控您的健康并获得终极的每日营养保障。所以有很多心理和生物学上的解释，解释了为什么我们可能会经历季节性情感障碍或季节性抑郁症。而这些答案中的很多都建立在
evolutionary psychology, despite how modern day society operates, you know, filled with work in busyness and social media and screens. We have to sometimes remember how our bodies and our minds were made to function. Back when humans were just, you know, simple creatures roaming around, focused on food and security, nature, exploring, reproduction and survival. These were the activities that our brains were hardwired to do. And those parts of our brains, they still exist. they still operate based on the same systems, based on the same processes and biology.
进化心理学的基础上，尽管当今现代社会的运作方式充满了工作、忙碌、社交媒体和屏幕。我们有时必须记住我们的身体和大脑是如何被制造来运作的。回到人类还只是简单的生物，四处游荡，专注于食物和安全、自然、探索、生殖和生存的时代。这些是我们的大脑被硬编码去做的活动。而我们大脑的那些部分仍然存在。它们仍然基于相同的系统、基于相同的过程和生物学运作。
And it's these very systems that can explain why when the seasons change, we might experience a shift in mood, such as is the case with seasonal affective disorder. So the first theory is that this form of depression is thought to be caused by changes to the body's circadian rhythm. This is otherwise known as the body clock. and our circadian rhythm kind of shifts based on the seasons and based on the different times of the year. circadian rhythm, for those of us who don't know what they are, they are physical, mental, behavioral changes that essentially follow a 24-hour cycle. So these natural processes normally respond primarily to light and darkness and affect how we behave. So they work by, so our circadian rhythm, it essentially works by helping to make sure,
正是这些系统可以解释为什么当季节变换时，我们可能会经历情绪的转变，就像季节性情感障碍的情况一样。所以第一个理论是，这种形式的抑郁症被认为是由身体生物钟的变化引起的。这也被称为生物钟。而我们的生物钟会根据季节和一年中不同的时间发生变化。生物钟，对于我们这些不知道它们是什么的人来说，是物理、精神、行为的变化，它们基本上遵循24小时的周期。所以这些自然过程通常主要对光线和黑暗做出反应，并影响我们的行为。所以它们通过以下方式工作，所以我们的生物钟，它基本上通过帮助确保
that the body's processes, whether that is the release of certain hormones, our body temperature, our mood, our wakefulness, our sleep, those processes are optimized at various times during a 24-hour period to match our environment. So it makes sense that we should be sleeping at night because we do not see in the dark. It is very difficult for us. So as those kind of evolutionary creatures, there's no point being awake then. It's a great period. for restfulness. But when the sun begins to rise, that's a great time to experience a spike in hunger so that we're motivated to go out and hunt or a spike in wakefulness and in energy. So all of those systems are controlled by our circadian rhythm. An irregular circadian rhythm can have a
身体的过程（无论是某些荷尔蒙的释放、我们的体温、我们的情绪、我们的清醒状态、我们的睡眠）在24小时周期的不同时间进行优化，以匹配我们的环境。所以我们在夜间睡觉是有道理的，因为我们在黑暗中看不见。这对我来说非常困难。所以作为那些进化出来的生物，那时醒着毫无意义。这是一个休息的好时期。但当太阳开始升起时，这是经历饥饿激增的好时机，这样我们才有动力出去打猎，或者是清醒和能量激增的好时机。所以所有这些系统都由我们的生物钟控制。生物钟失调会对
pretty negative impact on a person's ability to sleep and on our ability to function properly. and it can result in many health problems such as, let's have a guess, seasonal effective disorder. So this rhythm, this internal body clock, it's controlled mostly by our environment, in particular the presence of sun and daylight hours. So when these kind of hours change or shorten because of the winter months, it can cause problems. Alternatively, when we interrupt this normal circadian rhythm artificially or unnatural, By forcing ourselves to stay awake or something like that, we can also experience mood problems. So a lot of evidence on this relationship comes from studies of shift workers.
一个人睡眠的能力和正常运作的能力产生相当负面的影响，并且会导致许多健康问题，例如，让我们猜猜，季节性情感障碍。所以这个节律，这个内部生物钟，主要由我们的环境控制，特别是太阳和日光时间的出现。所以当这些时间因为冬月而改变或缩短时，就会引起问题。或者，当我们通过强迫自己保持清醒或类似的事情来人工或不自然地打断这个正常的生物钟时，我们也会经历情绪问题。因此，关于这种关系的许多证据来自对轮班工人的研究。
So people whose sleep periods are out of sync with their circadian rhythm. Let's think, for example, about nurses. That's such a great example. People who work shift work. Many of them will work at night and then sleep during the day, which contradicts the natural cues we're getting from our environment. and our biology and our body clock to sleep at night and then to, you know, work to hunt to gather during the day. So multiple studies show an increased prevalence of depression in night shift workers. One meta-analysis, it showed that night shift workers are 40% more likely to develop
所以那些睡眠周期与生物钟不同步的人。让我们想想，例如，护士。这是一个很好的例子。轮班工作的人。他们中的许多人会在夜间工作，然后在白天睡觉，这与我们从环境中获得的自然线索相矛盾。以及我们的生物学和我们的生物钟，晚上睡觉，然后在白天工作、打猎、采集。多项研究表明，夜班工人患抑郁症的几率增加。一项荟萃分析显示，夜班工人患抑郁症的可能性比白班工人高40%
depression than daytime workers, perhaps because they go against their circadian rhythm and their body clocks are out of whack, causing mood swings, difficulty controlling their emotions, and an irregular release of hormones. So this is where we get to the essential science of the matter, and we put everything together. So the shorter days during the winter months, when seasonal depression is most likely to occur, these shorter days, they confuse our body clock and lead to many of those symptoms that we've discussed. Another major reason behind the existence and occurrence of this disorder is the production and the release of melatonin. Melatonin is a naturally produced hormone that our brain releases in response to darkness.
抑郁症比白班工人多，可能是因为他们违背了他们的生物钟，他们的生物钟失调了，导致情绪波动、难以控制情绪以及荷尔蒙释放不规律。所以这就是我们进入事情的本质科学，我们将一切结合在一起的地方。所以冬天的日子更短，这时最容易发生季节性抑郁症，这些较短的日子混淆了我们的生物钟，并导致了我们讨论过的许多症状。这种疾病存在和发生的另一个主要原因产生和释放褪黑激素。褪黑激素是我们的脑部在响应黑暗时自然产生的一种荷尔蒙。
And for those of us who are familiar with melatonin, it essentially helps us sleep. Luckily, the body naturally produces melatonin at night and normally it's kind of triggered by, darkness and by the sun going down, which is why when we stay on our phones all night or stay on our phones after the sun's gone down, our brain kind of gets confused and we can experience a poorer quality sleep because our brain hasn't yet released that melatonin because it thinks that we're still active and the sun is still up due to that artificial light source. So the release of melatonin is incredibly important for our sleep and for our mood. As sunrise approach, the levels of melatonin drop, but as the sun goes down, the levels of melatonin rise.
对于我们这些熟悉褪黑激素的人来说，它基本上帮助我们睡眠。幸运的是，身体在夜间自然产生褪黑激素，通常它是由黑暗和太阳下山触发的，这就是为什么当我们整晚玩手机或者在太阳下山后玩手机时，我们的大脑有点糊涂了，我们可能会经历较差的睡眠质量，因为我们的大脑还没有释放出褪黑激素，因为它认为由于那些人造光源，我们仍然处于活跃状态，太阳仍然升起。因此，褪黑激素的释放对我们的睡眠和情绪极其重要。随着日出临近，褪黑激素水平下降，但随着太阳下山，褪黑激素水平上升。
It's why it's known as the Dracula of hormones. But if you have seasonal effective disorder, melatonin peaks earlier because the sun sets earlier, and it lingers for longer in the morning, making it harder for you to wake up and leaving you feeling really fatigued and groggy. In a similar vein, it may also be varying levels of serotonin. in our brain that cause this drop in mood during the winter months. This disorder is really related to serotonin, which is often known as the happy hormone,
这就是为什么它被称为吸血鬼荷尔蒙。但是如果你有季节性情感障碍，褪黑激素会更早达到峰值，因为太阳落山更早，而且它在早晨会停留更长时间，这使得你更难醒来，让你感到非常疲劳和头脑昏沉。同样，这也可能是血清素水平不同。在我们的大脑中导致在冬月情绪低落。这种疾病真的与血清素有关，血清素通常被称为快乐荷尔蒙，
and it's often implicated in clinical depression and other types of depression. So it makes sense that it's linked to seasonal effective disorder, right? If you already have an imbalance that can be made worse by all of these other factors combining, you know, your body clock is often the melatonin that your body needs is not being released at appropriate times and it also may just be that we're less able to do the activities that make us happy during the winter weather conditions being outdoors
并且它经常与临床抑郁症和其他类型的抑郁症有关。所以它与季节性情感障碍有关是有道理的，对吧？如果你已经有了一种不平衡，而这种不平衡可能会被所有这些其他因素结合起来而恶化，你知道，你的生物钟通常是身体需要的褪黑激素没有在适当的时候释放，这也可能只是因为我们在冬季天气条件下不那么能够进行让我们快乐的活动，比如在户外
being in the sunshine at the beach going for a lovely hike absorbing vitamin d which is of course important for our bodily functions seeing our friends having more time after work to be outside these are all really crucial and important contributors to our happiness. So when we don't have these because of the weather and because of the dark and because of the cold, this can also just contribute to a natural, behavioral and environmental decline in our mood and our overall well-being. So what can we do about it? Obviously humans are very smart, so we have come up with ways to address this. We're going to discuss some of those next.
沐浴在阳光下，在海滩上，去远足吸收维生素D，这当然对我们的身体功能很重要，看望我们的朋友，下班后有更多时间在户外，这些都是我们快乐的非常关键和重要的贡献者。所以当因为天气、黑暗和寒冷而没有这些时，这也可能只是导致了我们情绪和整体福祉的自然、行为和环境下降。那么我们能做些什么呢？显然人类非常聪明，所以我们已经想出了应对的方法。我们接下来将讨论其中的一些。
I'm guessing if you are listening to this episode, it's probably because you think you have seasonal depression or you can relate to some of these symptoms that we have discussed, maybe right now, maybe in the past. Luckily, for those of us who seasonal affective disorder is a problem for, there are many, many ways around it to ensure that we are able to function and live an active fulfilling life, even in the gloomy winter months. humans, I feel like I don't need to remind you, but we are incredibly adapt. You know, there are places in the, in like the world that are dark for like sometimes half of the year, like in Norway. So what do these people do? Obviously they have to find ways around it and these are some of the options that humans have come up with. If you want to go to a therapist or a professional and said, I think I have seasonal effective disorder and listed some of those symptoms that, that we talked about, one of the methods they'd probably suggest first to survive seasonal depression, it's called bright light therapy. So this therapy technique, it rests on the assumption of the science we discussed before that the presence and absence of light, mainly sunlight, is the primary contributing factor to seasonal depression. So the aim of this therapy is to re-synchronize your sleep pattern, resynchronize your energy and your wakefulness with the day and night cycles that
我猜如果你正在听这一集，那可能是因为你认为你有季节性抑郁症，或者你能与我们讨论过的一些症状产生共鸣，也许现在，也许在过去。幸运的是，对于我们这些季节性情感障碍是个问题的人来说，有很多很多的方法可以解决它，以确保我们能够正常运转并过上积极充实的生活，即使在阴暗的冬月也是如此。人类，我觉得我不需要提醒你，但我们适应力极强。你知道的，世界上有些地方一年中有半年左右是黑夜，比如在挪威。所以这些人做什么？显然他们必须找到解决的方法，这些是人类想出的部分选择。如果你去看治疗师或专业人士说，我认为我有季节性情感障碍，并列出了我们谈到的那些症状，他们可能首先建议用来度过季节性抑郁症的方法之一，被称为亮光疗法。这种治疗技术，建立在我们之前讨论过的科学假设之上，即光线（主要是阳光）的存在和缺乏，是季节性抑郁症的主要促成因素。所以这种疗法的目的是通过在你的日常生活中加入一个人造光源，将你的睡眠模式重新同步，将你的能量和清醒状态重新同步到
you would prefer by adding an artificial light source into your daily routine. So it essentially compensates for the lack of exposure to sunlight during winter that may be contributing to major depressive disorders, especially those with seasonal patterns. So it's pretty simple. You sit near this light box or this lamp. It has to be. It has to be. one that mimics natural sunlight. Like you can't just have a really bright light from like IKEA. It has to be a specific type of light, but it mimics natural sunlight. And studies and research has shown that bright light therapy, bright light treatment, if you do it consistently, first thing in the morning, it drastically improves our mood and the symptoms for a vast majority of people
你更喜欢的昼夜循环中。因此，它基本上补偿了冬天缺乏对阳光的照射，这可能是导致重大抑郁障碍的原因，特别是那些具有季节性模式的抑郁障碍。所以这很简单。你坐在这种灯箱或灯旁边。必须是。必须是。模仿自然阳光的那种。就像你不能只用宜家那种非常亮的灯。它必须是一种特定类型的光，但它模仿自然阳光。研究表明，如果你坚持做亮光疗法，亮光治疗，在清晨的第一时间，它会极大地改善绝大多数人的情绪和症状
with seasonal effective disorder. Pretty amazing, right? Like kind of simple, you know, we just, if we don't have enough light, we're not being exposed to sunlight, it's like playing games with our mind and with our mood and with our energy, just add artificial light. Like it's pretty self-explanatory. Another effective option is cognitive behavioral therapy or dialectical behavioral therapy, both of which are a form of talk therapy that aims to shift our negative or unhelpful beliefs and ways of thinking. The way that we think about things, the way we perceive process information and the thoughts and emotions we attach to these greatly influence how we experience the world and our mental state including as it is being as it has been suggested by
患有季节性情感障碍。相当神奇，对吧？就像挺简单的，你知道的，我们只是，如果我们没有足够的光线，我们没有接触到阳光，这就像在跟我们的心智、我们的情绪和我们的能量玩游戏，只需添加人造光。就像这是不言自明的。另一个有效的选择是认知行为疗法或辩证行为疗法，这两种都是谈话疗法，旨在转变我们消极或无益的信念和思维方式。我们思考事物的方式，我们感知处理信息的方式以及我们附加到这些上的思想和情绪，极大地影响了我们体验世界的方式和我们的精神状态，包括正如一些研究人员所建议的那样，
some researchers our propensity to experience seasonal depression so if you say things like i hate winter winter makes me so depressed i'm going to feel so depressed what a therapist might do is try and reframe and reposition those negative thoughts. So even trying to take it down a notch, saying something like I prefer summer to winter, that can result in a shift in our perception, and therefore our shift in our symptoms and in our mood. Because cognitive behavioral therapy for seasonal depression involves
我们经历季节性抑郁症的倾向。所以如果你说这样的话，我讨厌冬天，冬天让我如此沮丧，我觉得太沮丧了，治疗师可能会做的是试图重新构建和重新定位那些消极的想法。所以甚至试着降低一个档次，说些像我更喜欢夏天而不是冬天这样的话，这可以导致我们的感知发生转变，从而导致我们的症状和情绪发生转变。因为针对季节性抑郁症的认知行为疗法涉及
retraining your negative thoughts and your negative associations with the darker winter months, it is potentially the most effective treatment because it doesn't just change your environment, as is the case with artificial light. It actually changes your overall perception and your thinking. Of course, there are also medical solutions and medicinal solutions. I think there's this general perception sometimes that medication for any type of mental health disorder is somehow like cheating or the easy way out.
重新训练你的消极想法以及你对更黑暗的冬月的消极联想，它可能是最有效的治疗方法，因为它不仅改变了你的环境，就像人造光的情况一样。它实际上改变了你的整体感知和思考。当然，也有医疗解决方案和药物解决方案。我认为有时有一种普遍的看法，即任何类型的心理健康障碍的药物在某种程度上都是作弊或走捷径。
I don't think that's the case at all. I hope you don't think that's the case. It's just another way of taking care of ourselves and assisting our minds and our bodies to deal with the things that we find hard. Sometimes we need a bit of extra help. There's no shame in that. So if you are struggling with seasonal effective disorder, sometimes antidepressants can be something your therapist or a healthcare professional might suggest. normally what they'll tell you to take is something called a selective serotonin re-uptake inhibitor. So something like Prozac or Zoloft or Lexapro. If you want more information about this, please do your own research. But also if you want to hear someone else's experience, I did a whole episode on antidepressants and the science behind them. But long story short, if your seasonal effective disorder is in some way caused by lower levels of serotonin. SSRIs like Lexipo or others can help get those levels back up to what may be normal
我一点也不这么认为。我希望你不这么认为。这只是照顾我们自己并协助我们的心智和身体处理我们觉得困难的事情的另一种方式。有时我们需要一点额外的帮助。这并不可耻。所以如果你正在与季节性情感障碍作斗争，有时抗抑郁药可能是你的治疗师或医疗保健专业人员可能会建议的东西。通常他们会告诉你服用一种叫做选择性血清素再摄取抑制剂的东西。所以像百忧解、左洛复或来士普。如果你想了解更多关于这个的信息，请做你自己的研究。但如果你想听听别人的经验，我也做过一整集关于抗抑郁药及其背后科学的节目。但长话短说，如果你的季节性情感障碍在某种程度上是由较低水平的血清素引起的。像来士普或其他SSRIs的药物可以帮助将这些水平恢复到可能是正常的水平，
and that results in less of a drop-off in motivation, an overall shift in mood and well-being in those colder and darker months. So we've discussed medication, we've discussed cognitive solutions and behavioral interventions, but sometimes a change in environment is the best solution and can really help us out. A bit of a dose of the outdoors. Simply going outside can help boost your mood. If you have the opportunity to go somewhere warmer and somewhere brighter, even just for a weekend, go to the beach, go somewhere nice and sunny,
这会导致在那些更冷、更暗的月份里动力下降减少，情绪和整体福祉的整体转变。所以我们讨论了药物，我们讨论了认知解决方案和行为干预，但有时环境的改变是最好的解决方案，并且真的能帮我们一把。给户外一点剂量。仅仅去户外就可以帮助提升你的情绪。如果你有机会去一个更温暖、更明亮的地方，哪怕只是一个周末，去海滩，去一个阳光明媚的好地方
I would really recommend it. And the science proves that it would probably help you out. I used to do this all the time during the winter in Canberra. I would drive up to Queensland in the colder months for a few weeks during my uni breaks. Honestly, game changer. It was such a game changer when I was dealing with seasonal depression. You know, any kind of excursion, any kind of vacation, it's most likely going to just boost your mental health overall and a massive benefit if there's sunshine involved. Even finding a few minutes to walk outside just to help you get more natural light or sit near a window when you're
我真的很推荐。科学也证明这很可能会对你有所帮助。以前在堪培拉的冬天，我总是这么做。在寒冷的月份里，我会在大学假期的几周里开车去昆士兰州。说实话，这简直是个转折点。当我应对季节性抑郁时，这真是个巨大的改变。你知道，任何形式的远足、任何形式的假期，大多都能全面提升你的心理健康，如果有阳光的话，更是受益匪浅。哪怕只是抽出几分钟到外面走走，帮自己获取更多的自然光，或者在工作时、在大学里、无论你在哪里，坐在窗户旁边，
at work, when you're at uni, wherever you are, can be really helpful. Another thing I would do would be replacing the things that I really love doing in summer with something that I could do in winter so that I didn't have to lose that sense of enjoyment and my hobbies. You know, if my favourite summer, like I love swimming in the ocean, but having you swim in an indoor pool, going to the sauna, going to the spa, that's also great. And it also brings me a lot of joy. If you really like going for hikes out in summertime, based on where you live, you could still do that.
都会非常有帮助。我做的另一件事是用我冬天能做的事情来替代我夏天真正喜欢做的事情，这样我就不会失去那种快乐感和我的爱好。你知道，如果我最喜欢的夏天活动——比如我喜欢在大海里游泳，但去室内游泳池游泳，去桑拿，去水疗，那也很棒。这也给我带来了很多快乐。如果你根据你居住的地方，真的很喜欢在夏天去徒步旅行，你仍然可以做到这一点。
Maybe, you know, chuck on your big old puffer jacket. Go for a little walk around, put a scarf on, put your headphones on, grab a coffee, make an adventure of it. Find activities that still bring you joy or planned for things to look forward to in the future, to look forward to when it gets warmer, like a vacation or going home. home to see your family, anything that's going to make you feel optimistic and kind of bolster your mood and your overall well-being and your mental outlook on life. Finally, I will say, don't blame yourself. I think there's often a massive stigma and a massive culture of experiencing any form of mental illness or a disorder like seasonal depression and feeling like it's because
也许，你知道，穿上你厚重的老式羽绒服。去周围散散步，戴上围巾，戴上耳机，买杯咖啡，把它变成一次冒险。寻找那些依然能给你带来快乐的活动，或者为未来期待的事情做计划，期待天气变暖的时候，比如度假或回家看望家人，任何能让你感到乐观、提升你的情绪、整体幸福感以及对生活积极态度的事情。最后，我想说，不要责怪自己。我认为，经历任何形式的精神疾病或像季节性抑郁这样的障碍，往往会伴随着巨大的污名和庞大的文化氛围，让人觉得这是因为
we're not doing enough because we're lazy, because yada, yada. The list goes on and on. I'm not going to entertain them. It is absolutely not your fault. This is natural. It's a change in the weather. It's a change in your body clock, in your melatonin levels, in your ability to do things that you love. It's in no way your fault. But I do hope that by being educated a little bit more about the science, you found it useful.
我们做得不够，因为我们懒惰，因为诸如此类。这样的列表没完没了。我不会去理会这些。这绝对不是你的错。这是自然的。这是天气的变化，是你生物钟的变化，是你褪黑素水平的变化，是你做你喜欢的事情的能力的变化。这绝不是你的错。但我确实希望，通过对科学有更多的了解，你会觉得它很有用。
Sometimes psychoeducation and knowledge can be incredibly empowering so that we have a better understanding of what it actually is and a better understanding of the science and the psychology behind these things, why these things occur. And I also hope that if you are someone who is experiencing seasonal depression right now, that you feel a little bit less alone. I've been through it. So many of my friends have, you know, that study we talked about, one in ten people will have some form of seasonal effective disorder throughout their life. So you are definitely not alone. there are definitely things to get through it and you know the best thing about the seasons is that they always change and there will be summer again there will be sunlight again thank you so much
有时候，心理教育和知识可以赋予我们无与伦比的力量，让我们更好地理解它到底是什么，更好地理解这些事情背后的科学和心理学，以及这些事情发生的原因。我也希望，如果你现在正经历季节性抑郁，你会觉得自己不那么孤单。我经历过。我的很多朋友也经历过，你知道我们讨论过的那项研究，十分之一的人在一生中都会经历某种形式的情感季节性失调。所以你绝对不是一个人，绝对有办法度过难关，而且你知道季节最美妙的地方在于它们总是会变，夏天会再次来临，阳光会再次出现，非常感谢
for listening if you made it this far you're my best friend thank you for listening to the show thank you for supporting the show and joining for another episode if you found this helpful if this was something that you enjoyed please feel free if you feel cold to do so to leave a five-star review on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcast, make sure to follow only if you want to so that you know when new episodes are released. And thank you for listening along. I will be back on Friday for another episode of The Psychology of Your 20s. 2%.
大家的收听，如果你听到了这里，你就是我的挚友。感谢你收听这个节目，感谢你对节目的支持并加入又一期的节目。如果你觉得这很有用，如果你喜欢这个节目，如果你愿意的话，请随时在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方留下五星评价，确保点击关注（仅在你愿意的情况下），这样你就能知道新节目何时发布。感谢你的陪伴。我将在周五带着《你二十岁的心理学》的另一期节目回归。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。
Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
收听《2%》。这就是IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方上的TWA%。回顾播客。对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着通过我们的朋友、喜剧同仁和最喜欢的作家来理解我们是如何熬过那段日子的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听回顾。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and hosts care games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难学步》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男性穿着一身铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学步》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉利斯皮和迈克尔·拉尼尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。